how did The Wedding Singer evolve from
just another slapstick comedy into a
beloved Blockbuster hit here's what went
into making out of Sandler's retro
rom-com
according to Wedding Singer screenwriter
Tim Hurley there wasn't a conscious
effort to make the film drastically
different from Billy Madison or Happy
Gilmore the formula had been working for
both the fans and the box office
receipts so there wasn't a need to
reinvent it but as work got underway on
the pair's third film it ended up
naturally evolving into a more grounded
and more romance focused film clearly he
credits the fact that he had recently
gotten married as part of the reason why
the script began to become more of a
grown-up romantic comedy rather than
another silly romp about a bumbling
man-child he also says that the change
was inspired by Sandler's terrific
chemistry with Drew Barrymore and the
fact that test audiences didn't mind
scenes where her character was the focus
in Sandler wasn't on screen at all the
latter was deemed unacceptable by test
audiences of the previous two Sandler
films forcing those movies to cut almost
any scene that Sandler wasn't in Adam
Sandler wisely surrounds himself with
fantastic character actors in his films
and one of the best that he ever worked
with was Alexis Arquette while
Arquette's Boy George obsessed Wedding
Singer bandmate could have easily been
extremely one note and only useful for a
single punchline line George Stitzer
proved to Be an Effective and ongoing
presence throughout the film and was
responsible for just as many warm
moments as funny ones it seems obvious
enough that Arquette's performance came
from a place of affection for the singer
but it isn't always clear how the person
being parodied is going to take the
impression however during a concert with
his band Culture Club the day after
Arquette passed away in 2016 George paid
tribute to Arquette saying she played
him quote very hilariously and that he
enjoyed Arquette's work in the film he
then dedicated his performance of his
classic song Do You Really Want To Hurt
Me to Arquette as that was the song she
got stuck singing over and over again to
an increasingly frustrated audience in
her biggest scene in the film
God if you need a character to have a
real woman's voice you often need to get
a woman to write her words that is
exactly what happened when none other
than Carrie Fisher was brought in to do
uncredited script doctor work on The
Wedding Singer specifically to tweak the
dialogue of Drew Barrymore's character
in fact Fisher had been doing that very
thing for years and she's worked on a
number of different movies her earliest
examples of uncredited dialogue work
came in the original Star Wars films she
grew frustrated when Harrison Ford's
rewriting of his own Han Solo dialogue
began to have a negative impact on
Princess Leia's lines so she decided to
rewrite hers as well George Lucas liked
her work so much that he asked her to
write an episode of the young Indiana
Jones Chronicles and also help him with
the dialogue in the Star Wars prequels
Fisher eventually became a sought after
script doctor doing script work on such
films as Last Action Hero hook Scream 3
and Coyote Ugly Adam Sandler movies at
least the ones he either co-wrote or
were written specifically for him have
rarely been a hit with the critics it's
only when he appears in a movie that he
merely acts in like punch drunk love or
uncut gems that critics managed to
appreciate his work considering he has a
net worth of almost half a billion
dollars and was eventually deemed worthy
of 20 million per movie paydays that are
typically reserved for Blockbuster
action Stars it's clear that the movie
going public doesn't see eye to eye with
the critics he's probably just fine with
that with all that being said not all
Adam Sandler movies have been met with
unanimous disapproval from critics in
fact even Happy Gilmore managed to just
squeak by with a fresh rating on Rotten
Tomatoes but the Wedding Singer comes in
at a respectable 69 percent making it
the highest rated of films he's penned
and fifth overall of his movies to date
while a few of the higher rated movies
have comedic elements they are just as
equally dramas and the case can easily
be made that The Wedding Singer is the
highest rated pure comedy of Sandler's
career
is it your confidence
are you nervous about your penis Adam
Sandler movies were basically an annual
event in the 90s every fall meant a new
Adam Sandler comedy until New Line
Cinema messed that up when they decided
that the Wedding Singer would work
better if it was released close to
Valentine's Day
so they pushed it from its originally
planned fall 1997 release into February
1998. in hopes that couples would see it
as part of a romantic dinner and a movie
date it's hard to tell how much more
business the new release date actually
drove to the movie and how much of it
was just Sandler's huge star power at
that time but the box office tallies no
doubt made new line very happy still the
side effect was that 1997 saw Zero new
Adam Sandler movies while 1998 saw two
The Wedding Singer in February followed
by The Waterboy in November moviegoers
clearly didn't have Sandler fatigue at
that point as The Waterboy was also a
huge hit much bigger than the Wedding
Singer in fact with more than double its
domestic box office combined Adam
Sandler movies brought in roughly 242
million dollars at the box office that
year just in the U.S with only two
comedies that's an impressive figure no
matter how it's distributed
no
it's impossible to deny what a wonderful
on-screen couple Adam Sandler and Drew
Barrymore make their chemistry is
palpable from their very first scene
together in The Wedding Singer and it is
very easy to see how quickly they are
able to fall in love despite the
obstacles that stand in their way
Barrymore claims that she could tell she
and Sandler would be great together even
before the two met she says she
approached Sandler and revealed that she
believed them to be cinematic soul mates
a claim which she admits must have
sounded crazy to him at the time as
crazy as it might have sounded it proved
to be accurate not only were the two
great together in The Wedding Singer but
they re-teamed on 50 First Dates which
was yet another example of how well they
clicked on screen it would also be the
first time that Sandler Revisited a
female co-lead something he typically
does only in direct sequels like
grown-ups too in fact the duo couldn't
resist making a third movie together
which they did in 2014's Blended that
one might have failed to recapture the
magic of their previous pairings but it
definitely speaks to how well the two
actors get along
I think I'm in love with
with so many scenes in The Wedding
Singer taking place at weddings the
movie is full of crowds of people that
are difficult to keep track of among
those crowds is an actor who is at the
time mostly known only to stand-up
comedy nerds but would soon be familiar
to mainstream audiences as well during
Robbie's bitter performance of Love
Stinks he goes around and gets various
eclectic members of the crowd involved
from a woman with sideburns to a man
stuffing his face to an entire table of
people he regrettably refers to as
mutants among the group of people at
Table 9 that Robbie is cruel to is
comedian Brian posein in his first film
role he's easy to miss at first but once
the entire table belts out Love Stinks
and Unison he's much easier to spot
prior to The Wedding Singer Hussein
previously appeared in Mr Show with Bob
and David and he also landed cameos in
friends and news radio After the Wedding
Singer he scored a recurring role in
just shoot me and a steady stream of TV
and movie appearances after that Billy
Idol's appearance in The Wedding Singer
likely was a surprise to audiences at
the time but it was a pleasant one Idol
showed up as himself a rockstar flying
first class who would end up helping
Robbie win Julia Idol would later admit
that the main reason he did the film was
that his son was a huge Sandler fan and
he reasoned that if he was going to have
to see the movie anyway he might as well
be in it he showed up during the pivotal
scene where Julia finally officially
picks Robbie over Glenn and it ended up
being good for his career The Cameo
introduced him to a whole new generation
of fans who Idol says continued to
follow him for years after the fact
sir
is that Billy Idol
I believe it is oh my God although
Robbie sings A Lot in The Wedding Singer
both as part of his gig and just an
impromptu performances for Julia it
isn't technically a musical but it
became one when screenwriter Tim Hurley
teamed with Chad beglin and Matthew
scalar to adapt it into a full-fledged
Broadway production after previews it
officially opened in February 2006 and
ran until the end of the year on
Broadway before becoming a touring
production in 2007 and Beyond versions
of The Wedding Singer musical have been
performed in at least 30 cities in the
U.S as well as Canada Europe and
Australia while The Wedding Singer movie
was never going to rack up any Academy
Award nominations the musical was much
better respected by the Live Theater
counterpart the show was nominated for
five Tony Awards best musical best book
of a musical best original score best
choreography and best performance of an
actor in a leading role in a musical it
didn't end up winning any of those
Awards but it's still impressive that
The Wedding Singer musical can Proclaim
that it's a five-time Tony Award nominee
these days we take for granted the
ability to stream music but it wasn't
that way in the 90s in the case of The
Wedding Singer buying the soundtrack was
an easy and affordable way to instantly
own a collection of a dozen or so
classic 80s hits all in one place a lot
of people jumped at that chance as the
soundtrack went double platinum in the
U.S and also sold very well in Canada
Australia and the UK the soundtrack for
The Wedding Singer was so successful in
fact that it was the rare example of a
movie soundtrack later having a volume
2. the second installment included songs
from the movie that weren't among the
first batch like Adam Sandler's grow old
with you in fact both Wedding Singer
soundtracks are so well loved that
they've even since been re-released in
vinyl format which is fitting for a
collection of 80s Tunes as Adam Sandler
built up his resume of lead roles in the
90s there was a time when each movie did
better than the last at the box office
Billy Madison grossed 25 million dollars
Happy Gilmore topped that at 39 million
dollars and then The Wedding Singer blew
them both out of the water with an 80
million dollars domestic box office
tally needless to say Sandler had
arrived as a bankable comedy movie lead
sir one more Outburst I will strangle
you with my microphone wire you
understand me but what The Wedding
Singer also announced was the arrival of
Adam Sandler as a global Superstar while
his previous two films barely did any
business outside of the US The Wedding
Singer added a combined 43 million
dollars in its Global release pushing
him over the 100 million dollars Mark
worldwide for the first time granted he
had no trouble bassing 100 million
dollars just in the U.S on his next
handful or so of releases not counting
notable early outlier dud Little Nicky
but it's still important to take note of
the movie that first got him into the
nine-figure club and extended his reach
beyond the states and that movie was The
Wedding Singer Adam Sandler movies were
used a lot of the same actors but he's
also been generous when it comes to
finding parts for some of his old Pals
including Alan Covert Peter Dante and
Jonathan lochran giving them roles both
in front of and behind the camera
loughran has also served as Sandler's
assistant while covert has been a
producer on basically every Happy
Madison production today early in his
career Sandler initially didn't have the
cloud for this but on the Wedding Singer
Sandler could finally pull the strings
needed to not only get covert a major
part as Robbie's best friend but he also
brought Peter Dante into the fold with a
minor role in the beginning covert Dante
and lochrane would go on to have bigger
roles in subsequent Sandler movies and
I've even forged careers outside of
Happy Madison as well